you know coming off a perfect game I
think the beauty is to is to be critical
of that the same way you're critical of
a of a really rough game you know we
throw interceptions and fumble the ball
or you lose because of mistakes you made
you have to approach both of those the
same way and that goes for the media
that you you choose to look at or don't
look at it cannot be all the positive on
the great weeks and don't look at
anything on the bad weeks
[Music]
I believe that each and every one of us
has the power within ourselves to create
the life that we really want and I want
to help give you the tools to make that
happen
I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense
[Music]
today on the show is someone you've all
been waiting for you've all been asking
if I will interview him and it took me a
while it took me a while to be ready
because I wanted to have a little bit
more practice under my belt before I
took on someone so important in my life
as well as of course the reasons why I
was a little intimidated to talk to him
and interview him and that's because
he's so intelligent and he really he
really has such a deep respect for
someone who does their job well and of
course being such a newbie to this
interviewing game I didn't want to I
didn't want to be in my first five
episodes and and test run on him so I
got a few shows under my belt
feeling better feeling ready and and
then of course you know just
understanding you know what he you know
I didn't actually didn't think I was
gonna ask him what what we should talk
about but then I thought that's dumb
because you know we know each other so
well so why don't we talk about the
stuff that why don't we talk about what
he wants to talk about and and so just
communicate and so anyway on the show
today is Aaron Rodgers who is my
boyfriend and a phenomenal football
player and I hope that you get to know
him better I hope that you're inspired
by him and how he's lived his life and
the mindset and the tips and tricks he
uses to be more confident or to to do a
better job on the field and to live a
better life and be happier and it was it
was really fun I learned a few things
myself so I hope today's episode does
the same thing for you and you have fun
listening to it so thanks for tuning in
and enjoy the show come on make eye
contact it's like yeah but I'm like kind
of nervous about it and it is harder to
interview somebody you know really well
but do you well I mean
I think that I will probably learn some
things today I think yeah I think you
know me pretty well but I know you
pretty well so it gets hard to know
exactly where the line is and also where
to start
I've already to start and sometimes it's
easier from the outside looking in and
then there's oh there's also this
intelligence intimidation where you're
so smart and you have a deep respect for
those who are have their thoughts
collected and give a really good
interview with great insightful
questions that are respectful so that's
why I was worried so I thought we'd
start with intelligence then okay and
how you like when did you first know
that you were really smart for those who
don't know Aaron is very smart I was on
Jeopardy yes
celebrity jeopardy that was the first
time you knew no I don't know it's hard
to say when you know you're smart I mean
it has to be some sort of comparison I
think because when you're young it's
just kind of normal that you remember
things well and you you know statistics
and you know math and reading and I
think you don't really realize your
level until there's you're in school and
there's a comparison to other kids or
there was a group back in the day called
gifted and talented education or gate
and I'm sure that it could be
manipulated in today's day and age and
you could just pay somebody the proper
amount of money to get your kid and gate
there was a tag as well it's like
talented and gifted so they're a couple
you know programs like that for smart
kids I felt like you know we definitely
didn't have the money to pay anybody had
that been an option to get me in these
classes but twice a week I went over to
a different school and there was some
other kids from the area and we had like
a you know a few hours of
alternative studies you know we had a
different syllabus so it was during
those times where I learned how to play
chess
I learned whether I learned about Greek
mythology and now this is like in second
and third grade and when we're talking
about you know different types of topics
than those and regular classes and you
know a lot of stuff I learned in those
classes stuck with me and which is a
different type of experience I didn't go
it really just did that second third and
maybe fourth grade and then didn't do
that anymore
do you feel like it continued to
separate you obviously you get put into
gate because you're gifted and talented
what's the e education thank you um but
does that feel like it pulled you
further apart like the gap gap got wider
I mean you're talking about Greek
mythology I don't even know about Greek
mythology and I'm kind of interested in
it and I'm 37 well it's fascinating
that's some good stories about
everything they've made some movies
about it yeah you know you watch some of
these you know class that Titans I know
it had some mythological references a
lot of references and Marvel you know
the you know with the all the
superheroes and stuff and Thor and you
know that's a different set of mythology
but you know all that stuff is rooted in
actual mythology so it's not just way
out of left field I don't know that I
felt separated from my class I
definitely knew I had a retention level
of information I used to play this game
as a kid called strat-o-matic and my
first set was a 1970 set and basically
what it was was a board game you could
play by yourself or play against
somebody and it was based on even rolled
dice and they would have a corresponding
result from the dice so it was it was a
baseball game
and so I spent you know my sick days or
some days in the summer playing
strat-o-matic I remember of for
Christmas and probably 1990 I got the
1989 set which the 89 baseball set
included the two teams were the best
teams a year which were the Oakland A's
and the same Cisco Giants and that was
grow up in Northern California and you
would remember that also by the terrible
earthquake that happened the you know
the the earthquake that you know
collapse a lot of the bridges the Bay
Bridge we didn't get well is a big deal
on the west coast so anyway you know
playing this game I learned
multiplication and that cuz I had a fear
of batting averages and earned-run
averages and on-base average is so math
always came pretty easy to me in numbers
and percentages and fractions and ratios
and all that stuff and I've learned you
know five and six you know I could I
could retain the information I could
remember what Tony Perez's batting
average was and I could remember what
3/8 correspondent - on his specific
cards over year old a3 and then also you
know and hate I knew there wasn't you
know it was a home run for Tony Perez on
his card so whenever I was rolling I won
at 3/8 you know or Kevin Mitchell you
know - 12 was you know his big bunions
you still remember not I'm not sure if
that's correct but was showing an
example of the ability to retain
information and I was useful as strata
magic strat-o-matic numbers what a
strata Matic he didn't mean it was just
a board game you know your your plane is
sick that you're having a sick day you
said you'd played if you were home sick
or something and most people are like
drinking chocolate milk and watching
cartoons and you're playing
strat-o-matic and watching one of the
all-time greatest TV shows the price is
right if a cloud barker so that was ten
o'clock with prices right 10:00 to 11:00
and then you know then the soaps would
come on you know how sometimes you watch
some soaps no no no
I was playing strat-o-matic at that
point did you have kids that would cheat
off of you in school but they probably
would have wanted to yeah did you let
them know no it wasn't it wasn't that
you're a very abstaining man I can't
imagine that you'd be okay with that
what about a girl what if you like had a
crush on a girl and she was like oh a
definitely let her
how'd it when did you start watching
jeopardy we would go to my grandparents
in the summertime for we would call it a
week it's like each grandkid had it had
their week and kind of started when you
were maybe five or six and you got you
know it wasn't a week it was usually you
know two to four days usually and if it
was weekdays you know Grandma and
Grandpa or watching jeopardy so we were
watching jeopardy so you got used to
seeing Alex up there and can't say you
know got him the questions right but I
do remember enjoying listening and
learning and trying to follow what the
questions were and why they're asking
the silly way and why you were answering
in the form of a question and from that
point forward I wanted to be on Jeopardy
and Finance replying to your
grandparents in the form of questions no
I didn't do that I don't think I
understood the question apart um and
crosswords that's another thing I look I
appreciate your help with the crosswords
when I show some interest to hey maybe
I'll maybe I'll try one or do you need
any advice I mean you you asked me about
the cooking questions and the food
questions and I and I do okay in that
area but I've never finished a crossword
puzzle because I think they're insanely
hard and it's a totally different brain
function you of course do crosswords
every day how many crosswords a week do
you do I try all the ones on my New York
Times app
and you know I might try a local one if
I would get my hands on a paper in Green
Bay
I enjoy the USA Today ones as well and
then I'll go back and do some work I've
one time two time New York Times app it
has some archived one so you can go back
you know five years and so I like to go
down to Mondays and turn and then
Tuesday
Monday's are the easiest one and it gets
a little harder during the week right I
can't do Monday so you probably do like
eight to twelve a week yeah probably
and I've done zero how long have you
doing crossword puzzles for a long time
as well my grandparents used to do them
as well do you do them because you
thoroughly enjoy them or because it
helps keep you sharp Oh both yeah both I
mean I do enjoy them but also you know
I've had a number of concussions and you
worry about your future brain functions
and I feel like doing crosswords doing
Sudoku doing Ken can watching jeopardy
brushing your teeth with a different
hand tying your shoes in different
orders like there's a lot of different
things that you can do to stay sharp
mentally and I think that's one of them
crosswords what do you feel like is
there something out there where you're
like I think if I had time to do this
too I could really expand me crossword
tens anything anything intelligent like
read more well I read the read more yeah
definitely yeah I love to read when I'm
looking at these books behind you here
and there's some good ones on there I'd
like to read you know Steinbeck East of
Eden that's a I have I mean I have
probably half of these books I just
haven't read them you do have a giant
book collection yeah what's your top
five books
it's tough I mean I would say I love
crack hours work Jon Krakauer
he wrote to where men win glory which
was a book about Pat Tillman newsa
you know a hero of mine more than just
the obvious giving up a football career
to go to the military you know which I
thought was very selfless but the way he
lived his life I mean he was a
questioner he was a rebel he was
questioning his beliefs all the time he
was reading like crazy he was reading
Eastern religions he was always growing
and trying to learn new things and kept
some pretty cool Diaries that John talks
about in the book and and then his death
isn't shrouded in mystery you know it
was some crazy stuff to happen around
that but it's a really good book into
the wild also by Jon Krakauer about this
kid who kind of heads off and wants to
figure out his life in the wilderness in
Alaska and it's up passing away a really
interesting story because there's some
crossover between Jon's own life being a
mountain climber and being an
outdoorsman and another book that crack
I wrote called under the banner of
heaven which is about a couple guys who
use
organized religion to carry out a murder
and it's the history of this this
religion and it's very interesting book
I mean I just I really enjoy the way he
that he writes because there's so much
historical context and being a lover of
history he really breaks things down
easily when I was younger the shack was
an interesting book to me you know
because you're reading this book about a
religion that you grew up in and it's
talking about God being black and Jesus
being an ugly you know Arab looking guy
and questioning a lot of the like
westernized pictures of of Christianity
really I just love the book and
obviously it it faced a lot of harsh
criticism from the
yeah from the traditionalists but I
thought that was a really good book Rob
Bell was friend of mine great author and
he wrote a book called Love Wins which
was very meaningful to me and a number
of people I'm sure really enjoy that
book and then I don't know just kind of
depends and I enjoy reading books on JFK
I recently read the crazy expose about
you know just unbelievable detail about
his life the most dense book I literally
read it three times just to try and wrap
my head around the information in it
this is the loose one right yeah this
one that was all pages and I had him
just you're you probably went through
three highlighters highlighting this
well that's what you know that's what I
do and the people don't know why but I'd
love to highlight and underline in my
reading and then you went back
afterwards and wrote notes so much
information mm-hmm yeah and I want to
retain it well the first time probably
did the trick you were mentioning a lot
of books that had a theme of questioning
and you know spirituality is something
that we connect on on that level of
curiosity openness skepticism for sure
for me it's it's an area in a space that
I've gone through my own arc of exposure
and learning and finding at least where
I'm at right now with everything but
you've gone through what I would call a
much more extreme version of that like I
didn't grow up going church at all I
think I went on a couple of Sundays with
my girlfriend because we were out
drinking the night before and she felt
like she needed to go to church in the
morning I think one time she threw up
that didn't go good but that's about it
for me like probably five times when I
was a kid until huh I missed out and
what did I miss out on
stink bombs in church yeah I let off a
couple back in the day we have me and a
friend of mine but we it was after it
was never in the main church you know
it's always you know the breakout groups
you junior high group your high school
group you know I was a prankster Stillen
bring stir yes as you know I like to
prank you but ever know you like to joke
with me yeah from the beginning of the
day on but what's the question about
Church we're going with I don't really
pose a question yet I was just basically
laying the framework for something we
connect on my own like quick overview of
you know feeling like I've had my own
little art but you've had a bigger one
and like when you were a kid you went to
church all the time and then went
through your questioning and have
arrived where you're at now so maybe it
would be interesting for people to
understand kind of where you started
yeah accepted Christ when I was four and
a half years old
you know did the mountain II say in the
prayer you know go to church and that's
what you do on Sundays you you know go
to your breakout group or you know your
age-appropriate group or you stay in big
Church you know and on how old you were
or what the day was and you know singing
songs and kind of listening to the
message and that's just kind of normal
you know at some point in in high school
you know they always say they've been
kind of the church you know it's got to
become your own religion it's you know
it's you know it's got to me be
meaningful to me and to you and to me
and whoever's there and and so you you
know you go to a high school group and
you gotta be meaningfully well I mean
they just the church uses all this
language and code words and phrases and
you know as far as like what well like
born again
is the born-again the four-year-old
accepting Christ situation yeah but I
think there had to be another one as
well you know there's always you know
there's always kind of Rights that you
have to you have to do like RIT yes like
knowing you're like traditional
religious things you checkbox and you
know check marks you got it take care of
a little boxes you got it like going
yeah I like going to church and saying
the right prayer and wearing a promise
ring or you know we're a promise ring
but you know this was just little
idiosyncrasies in in religion which
looking back now are so silly and
antiquated and not important but for me
you know I think ever
most people that I knew Church was just
you just had to go your parents made you
go you wake up you put some clothes on
you go and you can't wait to get back
and watch the second game of the day in
the NFL on TV but uh I I started going a
young life and that's where I met Matt
Hawk who you know Matt's and Matt was
leading or young life group there for a
while and he was the first Christian
that I met where I was like man like
this dude like swears every now and then
he'd love sports she's got coaches
sports he's second on he's awesome dude
like he's taking a normal what seems
normal interests in my life and just a
really rad guy to be around I kind of
like you know the way that he talks
about Jesus and the way that he talks
about what it means to have a
relationship with Christ like that's
pretty cool so I enjoyed my time with
young life we did some amazing outreach
stuff you know we went to Mexico during
two spring breaks and built houses in
like Florido outside Tijuana rough areas
you know we we erected the you know from
slab to walls to tar in the room
stuck on the outside like we put
together you know homes for these folks
who were living and you know garage door
sides you know throwing together and
stuff and that was meaningful you know
that was like really meaningful work and
everybody went on those trips I think
you know it was emotional and and and
fun things to do and then you know when
when I got out of that area young life
and moved on to college and stuff
there's not really a young life for
college it's it gets into more organized
you know athletes in action and or
whatever it might be campus
organizations and I just didn't find any
connection points with with those things
and started questioning things and I've
had some good friendships along the way
that helped me you know to figure out
what exactly I wanted to believe in and
ultimately it was that rules and
regulations and binary systems don't
really resonate with me and so I slowly
slowly moved away from a lot of that
stuff and you know enjoyed learn about
other religions and meeting the Dalai
Lama yeah that's been a fun path to to a
different type of spirituality which
which to me is more it's been more
meaningful would you just sit would you
separate the two being spirituality and
religion like you were religious and now
you're spiritual I was I mean I think I
think both can work for people I do I
think some people just need structure
and they need tradition and stuff and
that works for them and I don't have a
yeah a problem with it that doesn't it
doesn't resonate with me yeah it's it's
well being a questioner like you are
it's hard probably in the middle of it
when it's happening to identify as that
or to see the signs that you that along
the way that would have woken you up
quicker maybe but now in hindsight how
far back
can you go and identify like yeah I
thought it was weird when I was four
like or whatever is there an example can
you identify when the skeptic and the
questioner and you was really present I
mean high school for sure cuz I had to
grips I was going I was going through to
church on Sundays and into young life on
Mondays and young life on Monday
welcomed everyone you know it's like
come as you are be there at 7:29 and
like be ready for some fun and it was
fun and we had a great time
church on Sundays it was like more you
know make sure you dress a certain way
and don't bring that person and this
person is going to get looked at
strangely if they show up and you know
again it's very black-and-white binary
and binary sense but I don't think it's
very welcoming why do you think it's
like that because there for many people
it where they didn't can be a crutch can
be a can be something that people have
to have to make themselves feel better
and because it set a binary it's us and
them it's saved and unsaved it's heaven
and hell it's enlightened and heathen
it's holy and righteous and sinner and
filthy and that makes I think that makes
a lot of people feel better about
themselves is it oh you know I have you
know I got Jesus and you know I'm saved
I'm going to heaven and there's only a
hundred forty-four thousand of us going
even though there's seven billion people
on the planet and then there's this
whole you know predestination belief
system within the sexes sec TS of
organized religion who believe that free
will is actually does not exist the way
we think it does and that people are
predestined to go to heaven or hell do
you think that's crazy
what are your thoughts on that whole
concept i just think it's so silly it's
so inconsequential and it's what do you
believe I just don't understand how you
can logically
believe that I and you know I don't know
how you can believe in a God who wants
to condemn most of the planet you know
to a fiery hell like what type of loving
sensitive omnipresent omnipotent being
wants to condemn most of his beautiful
creation to a fiery hell at the end of
all this that's why I enjoy the
historical context of a lot of things
because you go into some of the the
history of the Bible and the language
that was written in and you know Rob did
that in his book love wins and took some
heat for it because he talked about how
the idea of Hell in the word used was a
garbage dump outside the city it wasn't
this lake of fiery really yeah and that
struck a chord with a lot of people
because the separation the separation
from God is hell and that's something I
can totally agree with do you think that
that's here on earth right now what is
heaven and hell do you well I think I
think it's just that separation of of
that source energy so if you're separate
from the source injury you're living in
some sort of hell I think but if you
believe the source energy resonates
inside of you and resides there then
that's an Eden when you feel the most
connected and the most disconnected to
Source Energy probably the happiest when
I'm more connected when I'm in nature
you know it's just the scientific part
of it is the connection between your
body and the earth is it is a balancing
effect which I know you've talked about
in here before
grounding mm-hmm
I mean the disconnect I think it's when
is when you just kind of can't settle
your mind you know I think that's that's
the the biggest when the ego overtakes
the the column that's when I feel
disconnected when does that peak the
most when you're yelling at me
I do I do get loud I'm sorry for that no
I don't know I mean I think I think I
don't feel that disconnected in most
days that most times are really a lot I
think the key is finding that calm and
finding that balance and developing good
practices you know daily habits are
really important you know that what are
you what are a few daily habits that are
really important to you well I've been
you know regular habits yeah I mean I
think you're always growing I think
that's the most important thing I do
enjoy starting the day off and this is a
new one for me I showed you my five
things I'm trying to you know I enjoyed
practicing new mantras or or ideas or
thing reminders and one of them was
about being amazing and doing something
really uncomfortable and doing something
for somebody who can never repay you and
then changing a daily habit and then
being amazing that was like a five to do
list every day every day so that's been
how easy has it been to do that's yeah
that's hard you're like that was the
most uncomfortable when I rode with you
in a car and we know what was like can
you drive one of you in a car and not
say anything about here not trying to
give you answers come on gonna make fun
of myself I mean driving over
roundabouts is fine as long as the curbs
not too big but what are some things
that you've done where you like
good job good job me that was not
comfortable well a lot of us do some
uncomfortable conversations yeah
and I think in general people and men
sometimes have a hard time apologizing
sometimes girls do too yeah definitely
do didn't want to say that but yeah so
just realize on how your energy and your
attitude can affect other people so you
know you got 63 just alpha ego
personalities at work and that's just
the players name the coaches so you know
apologizing to your teammates can be
tough sometimes if you think it's
unnecessary or maybe I didn't affect
that person you know like it won't but
the language of apology is the language
of connection and love and I found some
pretty cool when you do apologize to
their good I do
wear that and all that but when one for
me you know it's it's it's one of those
uncomfortable things sometimes where you
try and sense a situation and how it is
energetically and doing you know doing
that uncomf like and I don't feel like I
need to apologize every time you do some
great energetic thing happens and
connection with a teammate or coach and
not all the time but most of the time
you know like I was saying something to
a teammate and I enjoy a good as you
know a good debate and we were kind of
talking and it got into it and I felt
really good about my point which I'm
sure you're not surprised when I felt
like I was making sense I mean if you
felt really good about it that's saying
something then getting some you know
some justification from some other guys
who were kind of listening the
conversation after the conversation I
just thought about it from his
perspective and I thought man I hope he
didn't feel like I was getting it up on
him returning to be little were you know
I was trying I would just feel like I
was dropping some knowledge at that
point why did you need help
for Moo you said you had all kinds of
team it was more like they were
co-signing they were like yeah so it was
like playing dice and everybody's round
in a circle but instead this was a great
debate so I just I just said this will
be my uncomfortable thing I de I'm just
gonna I'm gonna give them a really
really good apology even though I I
don't know if I need to you know look
and I don't want to make things
uncomfortable at all or maybe him be
like hey stop it don't apologize you
know then I apologize and it was okay it
was warranted so I kind of checked
myself like yeah okay yeah that was that
was important thing to follow the wrong
you are a very much an energetic ball
like your your energy can ittan it
affects the entire room good or bad like
it's very present yeah it can be bad it
can it's very powerful but you also have
an incredible ability to notice other
people's and so your your energy antenna
is super on it's very frustrating no
it's actually not frustrating it's just
it's just
hmm it can be more work like for us
because I mean I remember riding in a
car I remember riding the car one time
and you made you said something and then
I instantly had a thought and I just
turned right and looked out the window
and you were driving and you go what
what just happened what's wrong and I
was like can't I be with my my thoughts
for just a second without you asking and
of course then the open me comes out I'm
like it's fine and I'm like well
actually you know right because I I
almost always say like most of the time
I say no you have sinners you have some
total tells when you say fine it is not
fine
fine it was fine same for something
insecure neurotic and emotional so
frantic frantic so you know you can feel
that but you can feel that with other
people I'm sure - yes it's just a really
useful tool
I would think but it's also work how
like how early did you notice that about
yourself where you could just and that's
a bit of a harder one because I don't
feel like we talked about that right you
don't talk about like oh I feel your
energy especially going to church now
talking about I mean you know you're
probably not using the language of
spirituality and energy when you're you
know when you're in that kind of an
environment but it's so there have has
it always says that did it go unnoticed
for a really long time I always found
myself in leadership positions growing
up in sports you know I wanted to be
forward or goalie and soccer I wanted to
be on the mound pitching or playing
shortstop I wanted to be point guard in
basketball you know I want to be
quarterback obviously in football I
think that desire to be a leader I
understood at an early age some of the
responsibilities about raising the level
of your teammates play and being in tune
with how the team is melding together
and knowing when emotion can really add
to the the moment and the squad and then
morale so I understood that at a young
age and then I was never never a rah-rah
guy never a big get in front of the team
and speak I just I just saw that people
were really good at it and knew that I
had sometimes got in those situations
and I just got nervous I didn't want to
say the wrong thing and so I think that
allowed me to you know to really tune in
to the energy part
you know when you don't have a
understanding of spiritual things you
call it like mood and you call it vibe
you know you tell you call it good
instinct yeah
gut instinct yeah yeah and so you always
felt like I had it you know good good
and say the right thing a new kind of
what to say in the right moments or how
to act or who needed you know pat on the
butt and who need to smack on the head
you know like who how you needed to
respond to certain guys and I took a fun
I always you know to the story time the
time I took a fun coaching class when I
was at junior college
it's taught by Russ Crutchfield who was
the basketball coach at Butte and he
might still be to this day but it was a
fun I really enjoyed that class because
it it put kind of words in psychology in
terms to the last stuff that I knew kind
of intrinsically about how to have a
lead how to be accountable how to look
for ways to inspire guys how to motivate
try and motivate people because it's all
about coaching it's all about how to
coach better and coaching is a term
associated with sports but there's
coaching in life and and it's really
just how to figure out what buttons you
were friends or teammates or co-workers
or whatever respond to best and their
responsibility falls on using that the
right way like not you know pushing your
buttons because I know which buttons key
ignite you and which ones don't
it's too easy sometimes well that's
because your antennas super tuned in for
me the suit this really transitions easy
to an aspect of your game which everyone
finds phenomenal I find it as well but I
know you so well I can kind of
get to this spot where how you know the
two minutes you know two minutes at the
end of the game and you start making the
calls and it's almost like I can I don't
know I feel like everyone can almost
feel that you know it's going down like
you're gonna you're gonna you're gonna
come through and you're gonna get
whatever it is that you need whether
field goal range or a touchdown to
either tie it up or win the game like
you're you're the most clutch player
ever and I feel you know your mental
shift into a new space where you you
know there's a sense for that can you
feel that
yes what does it feel like yeah very
calm when I was six I was five
and I watched Joe Montana take the
Niners down the field against the
Bengals and threw a touchdown to John
Taylor for the win
and I remember thinking and that's what
I wanted to do you know then
fast-forward 14 and I'm watching MJ
Michael Jordan last game with the Bulls
and you know he crosses up Russell at
the foul line and drains a mid-range
shot and that's what I always said like
I want to do that like I want the ball
in the clutch moments and you realize
most people don't think that like a lot
of people are overwhelmed and Men
thought that just seems normal I think
people would want to be they want to be
great but they don't probably think it's
possible so you know yeah so think to
yourself I want the ball but you believe
you can do it that's the difference we
have to do it first you know I think my
first year started in 2008 we didn't
finish off with all those games now we
scored on a few of possessions and then
didn't stop them a couple times but we
weren't really efficient and we got
better from that moment on I think over
the years when I first started I'm
two-minute drill you know I have to sync
ly remember you know two huge ones my
sophomore year JV we beat Enterprise I
hit my best friend in high school
wrangle Branson on a post round for a
touchdown and then we beat Chico high
our rivals on a big 90 yard drive 90
yeah we backed up and drove all the way
down and hit Ryan on a slant route for a
touchdown but in those moments you just
you know even at a young age the
confidence was we were going to do this
and I think when it becomes an
expectation really its transcends
expectation it's more of a manifestation
you know I think you just have a supreme
belief that you're gonna get it done and
like Manny wrote in our QB room you know
guy said this at one point I said speak
[ __ ] to life and what does that mean it
just means talking things into existence
oh great oh yeah creating a yeah
thoughts become things yeah I'd say that
all the time creating the organizational
zeitgeist that is constantly manifesting
positive things to happen and I think
there's power and in that I think if you
take out the esoteric nature of some of
the words you know we're using it's
really about belief and confidence yeah
it's about a confidence that we're gonna
do it and and then the belief on
everybody who's contributing that we
will achieve the result we want to and I
think there's it's there's power in it I
think if you look at our history and to
mojo you know over the course of my 12
year starting it's not like we score
every single time
but there's almost a thought now out
there and really most importantly on our
squad that we're definitely scored but
it's not like that's one hundred percent
of time but but when the thought is
there man if you feel like it's for sure
gonna happen and that belief is very
powerful that's expanded into more than
the last two minutes like you know I
obviously watch all the games and
there'll be five minutes left in the
game and you're down by what seems like
you know probably something that you're
not going to come back from and the the
guys commentating on the on the game are
like Bill but you never count them out I
mean you just never know they all say
that you have earned that you have done
it you have manifested that ability it
helps yeah if everybody in the stands is
pulling in the same direction how does
that feel the people in the stands how
does that affect you I think I'd be
extremely positive yeah I think I can I
think from a sheer entertainment factor
I you know I do go into a game no one
that there's multiple people thousands
of people probably in the stands we've
never seen me play and I heard Michael
Jordan say this see this years ago about
motivational things that he that he uses
and so I'm stealing it from him but he
said there's people in the crowd they'd
never seen me play in person and I want
to put on the show every time I take the
court and I was that kid in 1998 I was
sitting in the top row of Arco Arena and
I got to go down in Sacramento and got
to watch him play in his last season
with the Bulls and he scored 30 and you
know they won by 30 it was like you know
101 71 or something maybe have this
course probably off but but I do know he
scored 30 and there's nothing like
winning by a hundred when you were no
basketball when you were in sixth grade
or anything you know but I think there's
that pride of performance that knowing
that there's people that haven't seen
you play so
but on the show do you ever stop and go
like damn that was pretty good like for
example when you threw your perfect game
you weren't like yeah that was like yeah
you know I mean you are somewhat
dismissive of it so are there still are
you able to impress yourself are you
able to even let go wow I can't I can't
believe I can even do that on some level
like where is my where is my headspace
that allows me this super ability I
think you have to have that otherwise
you and we live in this world where
you're just not happy and nothing is
fulfilling more enjoyable and I never
want the joy of the game to be robbed
based on unreal expectations or a need
to be stoic all the time and that feel
like I have it all together and not
going to show any emotion no I love I
love celebrating showing emotion and but
do you feel it I definitely do it no I
definitely feel it I think you know
there's times where you make plays that
are special but they maybe don't feel
special because you know either you've
visualized that or done it before in
practice or done it before another
situation and didn't feel like it was
over-the-top amazing and there's some
times you're like that's pretty [ __ ]
good that was that was pretty amazing
what are you what's the like they're
most proud moment well a couple the Hail
Marys I just feel like you know the one
in Arizona that throw was a special one
because I'd done something similar that
in practice probably years before but to
harness that energy in the timing and to
get her right in the bill throw a ball
that got an area now Jeff Janis made an
amazing catch you know and and if he
doesn't make the catch it's a it's a
nothing play with lose a game 2013 and
nobody really talks about the fact that
you know it's one of the greatest first
wild card playoff games ever but because
he did catch it the Polly gets obviously
a lot more attention and the throw was
the degree of difficulty it was tough
and I'm proud of that throw and that's
run into play it's Detroit that the Hail
Mary that one you know for the ball to
come out that way it's one of those
dream scenarios where you know in other
sports is its center Center center of
center of center of clubface in golf or
around the label in baseball we don't
feel anything or just that release in
basketball where you just it's just
perfect like that ball came off perfect
and when as high as I possibly can throw
it and as far as I could throw it with
that height and then for Richie to to
come down with out and catch it again if
that you know if he doesn't catch it
it's just like man I was pretty sweet
throw and then that's it but instead
because he caught it you know that plate
goes down obviously in my career is one
of the most special there were other
games where you get into a zone and
everything seems to come easy almost you
eyes back your head and the movement is
perfect and the balls coming out around
target those are fun but like I said the
Oakland game where I had a perfect QB
rating was not the best game I've ever
played
I think for me there wasn't you know
multiple multiple throws where I was
like that was yeah that was pretty good
it was just more like yeah I kind of did
my job here I threw an accurate bow
there thrown a curve ball there and bing
bada boom you know 100% 8+1 58.3 rating
which is the most arbitrary number ever
their loser is so ridiculous
why wouldn't they use a hundred that
would be silly what happens when it's on
the other side when you don't have a
game where you feel like you played up
to your potential
and you feel bad or you feel like you
weren't your best self
let's drink did
I mean Tirico tried you try to get you
to say that you would drink some of my
wine which you drink scotch I did I mean
you know that right
wait I do enjoy your wine we drink your
wine this is something that your ability
is superhuman
for sure but sometimes there are still
human games where you make mistakes and
and so I think it's important for people
I also you know care how you deal with
that like how do you deal with where's
your mind go
what do you practice what do you think
about what do you do for the next you
know six days until the next game how do
you get over it how long does the like
disappointment last you know what's that
like I think first you have to talk
about the other side first just to give
perspective you know coming off a
perfect game I think the beauty is to is
to be critical of that the same way
you're critical of a of a really rough
game you know we throw interceptions you
fumble the ball or you lose because of
mistakes you made you have to approach
both of those the same way and that goes
for the media that you you choose to
look at or don't look at it cannot be
all the positive on the great weeks and
don't look at anything on the bad weeks
for me it's really unless there's
something that I need to see that it you
know Tom Fanning sends me it's you know
you don't look at much I don't I don't
look at any of that when we win we lose
you lived it and that's the mind so yeah
and that's the mindset it has to be you
know you have a place for all that and
the place is I'm critical of the wins
I'm critical of the losses what I can do
better
how my attitude was out there how my
leadership was what plays don't have to
be smarter about how my preparation was
the those weeks what made it better than
others I think you're always self
scouting that's a you know football term
but in life you're always kind of soap
scouting you
to take an inventory on what's been
working lately habitually you know like
what habits have I been doing that work
for me what do I need to change what
would I like to do better you know I
think that's just kind of a lifestyle so
when it's a lifestyle
then you know you don't get to high and
low with it so you do the same thing
either way really yeah I mean I always
say I hate losing more than I love
winning and I really love winning so you
hate the feeling but you have to find a
spot for that feeling because what do
you mean find a spot like what what does
that mean you Kimi's deal with it and
put in its place it can't be sticking
with you okay then the marginalized yeah
you know the next week so when's the
first time you address it after a game
cuz first I mean people are talk to me
you're impressive after you get home
from a game that doesn't go well or even
when I've talked to you after a game
that doesn't go well you like yeah you
know whatever all right I'll be home you
know you're able to compartmentalize
seemingly to me really well or get over
it really well
what's definite not that I don't care I
mean no I I know I know but this ability
to turn that off is well balanced it's
the balance I think you have to have
that balance you know it's fine my
cheery attitude I don't think I'm
talking like that to you know Leflore my
teammates or get see your hack you know
like we're pretty awesome out how I
played what we had to do better you know
it's frustrating when you lose it's
great when you win but there's still
things to clean up all its yeah
it was probably no game that has more
self analyzation than football I would
think as far as sports well they all do
now I mean they are all did they
definitely all do no they don't have as
many days to look at that film though
well they get to they get to repeat
pretty quickly yeah basketball plays two
or three a week and baseball plays you
know four or five a week and hockey
plays two or three weeks you have a
chance to kind of rebound football you
have to sit with it for longer so I want
to learn over the course you career like
how - well racing it was the same I mean
racing was one weekend to the next and
so you know always saying like you're
only as good as your last race and you
have to sit on that thought and that
feeling for for one from one week to the
next and I have for sure as you know my
spirited attitude I have for sure let a
bad weekend slip into the next to the
next and then all of a sudden you spiral
out of control so I think it's harder to
not have a game to come back to right
away than it is to have to sit you do a
really good job thank you yeah some
cupcakes yeah I make some cupcakes when
you come home only if you will now
quickly only if you win I'm just kidding
you know I just make your cupcakes
anyway I do vanilla cupcakes healthy
cupcakes well I tried what so yeah what
some health fitness huh you know I love
it so what has changed in the from
meeting me let's say even we could go
back further if you want but like what
has changed depth health wise food wise
my friend Tim always sees me back when I
broke my foot no.6 and no.7 offseason I
was falling around the Santa Clara
basketball team because two of my long
longtime friends were playing big
minutes for him and so me and my buddy
Tim would you know go to a bunch of
games and Tim being as well as Morgan
and he likes to bring up my fat days
because I got on the scale at the WCC
the West Coast Conference championship
in March and what year was this miss
2007 yeah I broke my foot at a fifth
metatarsal fracture and that skill
number may have kicked the past to 40
who he loves to bring that out but 15 a
lot changed after the 15 season I had
surgery on my knee and I decided to
during my rehab time to kind of cycle
off the area I've always had a major
sweet tooth I love just about anything
sweet breakfast for dinner
waffles of course I mean did it make you
mad my when I would judge the amount of
peanut
and maple syrup no because I have a love
affair with food nothing put a damper on
it yeah okay it didn't make you feel bad
or I'm just trying to do my best duty to
know like I wanted to make some changes
that cut you know dairy out of my normal
diet and I am in no way as strict as you
are you're way more disciplined than I
am but I've found that you know like you
don't do any processed sugar you don't
do any dairy you cook love to cook at
home all the time and you're a fantastic
chef obviously but you the products that
you use the types of vegetables and
fruit and and then the fact that you
never have any cheat days or meals
really how does that make you feel it's
impressive
oh yeah it's impressive but that's
definitely helped with with my diet and
you know one of the positive helped okay
well what does that mean well I've
gotten down to a weight that feels a lot
more comfortable on my body and my
joints you know being under 220 now for
a number of years has really I think
helped me with my mobility and my knee
pain and my swelling in my body just as
stuff you're eating I think I understand
how much that affects your performance
and different things can cause
inflammation in the body and
inflammation as we know is is a killer
not just a short term you know frustrate
or of knees and ankles and limbs and
joints but you know that causes
disruption cells that cause disease and
cancers and different things and being
mindful about the stuff you're eating
and where it comes from and what type of
organic it is is it real organic or is
it did you pay attention Yeah right did
you pay attention that before me or was
that no he doesn't fifteen with things
changed or was that fifteen was really
just cutting out dairy and then you know
you help me read labels and
be more aware of where it's coming from
and then be more aware of what adds like
I enjoy eating out you know I enjoy you
know you know going out to dinner and
having a big meal and reminding how some
of those meals are cooked and they're
not a butter that's use and fat and yeah
for anyone listening restaurants make
all their food taste better through
sugar fat salt all of it like fat sugar
salt you will always have way more salt
that's why when people eat at home if
they always eat out they do at home not
like it sounds bland it's like yeah
because there's not a gallon of salt and
sugar and fat on your food and now you
can eat like that if you want but you're
gonna be fat and you're gonna be
unhealthy and so I'm healthy for sure
well you know portions are everything
calories are king you can eat like total
[ __ ] and eat a thousand calories a day
and lose weight yeah for sure but the
problem is is you're not going to have
very many bites when you're eating that
way yes
do you feel like it's helped recovery
because I mean it was a shocker to me to
just see how beat up you real I mean and
I feel that saying that like I'm like
how did I not know but you know cuz
football players get hit all the time
but you yeah you guys get beat up and I
mean you come home and even games where
you don't get hit which happens every
now and again we don't get hit at all
you know you can still feel like the
aches and pains but when you do get hit
I mean you know I mean looking at your
legs you have scabs all over the place
from where you get kicked where you fall
over when someone stands on you probably
when you know I mean there's that you're
always you're always dinged up do you
think the food helps that I think so you
notice a difference or do you think it
works well I just think I mean as you
get older like a you're affected
differently about some of the hits for
sure so that plays a little bit of a
factor but I think the diet definitely
definitely helps cuz you know I laugh a
lot of stuff that you can see and really
tangibly notice
look at the picture 101 Super Bowl or
picture of me as a young player to now
like my face is super like full fat I
would say when loaded then yeah I mean
like my if you look at like a history
and they did that at some point I like
the Packers website it's like my
headshot from my go file oh yeah
you know might go look fat if I look at
that skinny face now yeah sorry happy
where you're at an hour which is don't
no no I mean I definitely look I miss
miss blizzards for sure how do %
what kind Oreo and Reese's peanut butter
cup mix mix together yeah I miss you
know going after gallons of ice cream
gallons oh yeah I miss starburst
jellybeans for how much I've ice cream
if you ate in one sitting
no I mean I could polish off the dryers
you know half gallon for sure without a
doubt like it's nothing I'd polish off a
bag of starbursts jellybeans like I I
love the sweets I'm proud of you I don't
miss yeah I don't miss the way I felt
and I do think it helps my performance
it helps my recovery and I'm glad you
know you're such a good cook and you
enjoy doing it
I do you know every now and then when
you're gone sneak into couple you know
cheat meals but well the chocolate chips
supply in the pantry goes way down if
it's open if the chocolate chip bag
let's see their health each other they
are dairy-free they are like a vegan
chocolate chip I actually just think
enjoy life chocolate chips are the best
anyway but yeah and the problem is
though babe I go to make us cookies and
then there's no chocolate chips and the
bag is still there but it's empty the
best part is sometimes when you hide
them and you think I'm not going to be
able to find them because I don't try
real hard they're just like behind the
basket like I went in there one day
she was gone and I wanted these it's
like these chunks they're not like
little chocolate chips yeah man that I
knew is the 3/4 bag minimum it's like
that's how much you were yeah no one
that was in there I was left no I
couldn't find it I was like she wouldn't
have taken so I walked out of it 20
minutes later she was late I was
thinking I was like probably hit him
back in there it's like not well lid
back in the pantry like you triumphant
like I've found well I'm glad and you
know I am a little stubborn to that I
don't like to cook two meals mmm I'm
just stubborn period sorry let me
rephrase that better I'm really stubborn
and in the stubbornness I don't like to
cook two meals so I'm grateful that you
like my food and you eat it otherwise
you'd be hungry I just want to totally
change subjects and get off of that and
just ask something fun we were talking
about fun things though because
blizzards are fun right hiding the
chocolate chips are fun but what other
things do you like to do for fun I
really enjoy stuff we talked about I
enjoy watching jeopardy I enjoy reading
they enjoy doing crosswords I would
really enjoy being out in nature I like
traveling you know we've been at some
fun where's your favorite place we've
gone oh I spent some fun trips I mean
the Dalai Lama trip was so much fun you
know doing Sephora doing the outreach I
mean the Dalai Lama being with amazing
folks on the plane you know we talked
about just the conversations yeah and
learning and Lama tee you know and all
his great wisdom
he told me I should write a book called
the speed of consciousness he was doing
his little spiels in the back of the
plane telling us all about the the Lama
life yeah
Lama perspective I like New Zealand yeah
well you know we talked about that
that's coming back from there
it's like no such a great we both said
that great country north and south you
know a lot of really great people
beautiful sights you let you know you
let us go to Hobbiton the one day which
was amazing help facilitate habitant I
had a good time I mean look you know
kids movies doesn't mean I judge you
much just because you had a jolt in
childhood have been watch any kids
movies that's true I did not watch kids
movies I don't even like cartoons like
I'm not a cartoon you know that like
it's just not interesting we watched a
scooby-doo growing up but that was about
it and Shira if anyone remembers Shira
nobody does but New Zealand for sure so
traveling and hiking and love golf as
well enjoy golf coughs a good escape
love of the ocean you know water being
around the ocean or lakes
you know Lake Tahoe's a fun trip in the
summer and super fun yeah cold lake but
beautiful weather refreshing will recent
cold no I jumped in once you saw me went
out on the dock jumped headfirst
refreshing Tahoe plunge you are I mean
you might be a California boy but you're
the Wisconsin weather has conditioned
you 15 years will do that do you think
your mind has can do you think you're
you're eventually conditioned or
physically wonder-percent as those great
folks know up there we are just better
at dealing with it right here nobody
truly I was born in Wisconsin dude but
you haven't lived there 15 years I'm
talking with my constituents up there
and beautiful I left home when I was 16
so I get a full state of Wisconsin we
are better at dealing
that we are I don't think anybody walks
outside on a negative 10 day and goes
look at this this is amazing
I think about there I go you can't break
me you can't break me weather would you
rather have seasons or always be in 74
and sunny so when I was a young player I
remember somebody was talking about how
they you know just love four seasons of
Wisconsin so - and how do you you know
you must not enjoy seasons
I said you being from California said
and I said no I said I love I love
California and I love the seasons - I
said California just eliminates the
seasons I don't like the cold ones being
from the Midwest you know what I used to
say well where would I go for a vacation
then that's what I told myself so that
the I live in bad weather so I can go on
vacation it wouldn't be very special if
I lived in an all the time well that's
the thing you've never you you've never
been a cold-weather vacation person no
because when you grow up in California
vacation doesn't have to mean Beach it
can mean mountains yeah yeah you know
it's different when you live in the
Midwest when you think of vacation
you're like yeah where's the warmth yeah
we have snowbirds heading down to
Florida and Arizona yeah baby we can't
escape this whole conversation without
talking about aliens we can't and you
had an alien encounter I didn't have an
alien encounter what you told me about
an encounter and you talked Jefferson no
I said I had I said I've had some UFO
absolutely thing that's just the same
thing could be government secret
programs could be totally based on alien
technology alien maybe or maybe just
super technology that we don't know
about I would like to have you refresh
my memory of the story when you saw
something in the sky that was not normal
yes I was in New Jersey I was with dear
friend
who has backed me up publicly on the
story after I told it on that on the you
make it weird podcasts with Pete Holmes
he was midnight we heard an alarm we
went outside it was a beautiful snowy
night and in the sky we saw something
moving through the clouds that the only
reference that makes sense for people
who've seen Independence Day is that
seen when the spaceship is coming
through the atmosphere and the airplanes
can be toward it and it's just kind of a
moving orange object that's what it was
in the sky moving at a high speed low
speed well it was moving at it's not a
high speed it was it was just so large
and unnatural it was unnatural 100% it
wasn't like oh you saw you know some 747
that was no this was tremendous size and
moving left the right glowing orange
like fire and we were just all frozen
just mean my buddy and his brother and
just frozen and it goes out of sight
can't look at each other like what was
that and then nobody spoke because if
everybody's ever been in a moment where
it's something happens it's so shocking
for me personally maybe not for you cuz
you're a talker but for me words are
useless yeah they're useless in that
situation because you don't even know
would you it's all I'd even describe it
and so there's that moment there's 30
seconds of like and then before we could
say anything fighter jets
you ever been to a flyover or an airshow
you know what that sounds like
and I've been the likud long time and
scene
hasn't been the airshows as a kid you
had seen Top Gun like you know what that
sounds like
right it's four of them you know and
then nothing we turn the news on nothing
check the papers dig the next day
nothing now there was another alarm that
went off so that's what triggered us
because I was up in my room about to go
to sleep and heard this kind of alarm
noise in the distance obviously came
downstairs we all did
so then we finally started settling down
a half hour later one I am the alarm
goes off again we run downstairs nothing
we wait out there for twenty minutes
nothing you know hmm
so after that you know yeah I don't know
how you can be you not be changed I
didn't really ever talk about it a whole
lot to just a small group of people but
I started with only yours
this was 2005 February January February
yeah and so you did certain research and
and also we found out that that was the
alarm at the nuclear plant Oh usually so
there's a lot of nuclear activity and
and that's when I did the research later
and I find that there are a number of
UFO sightings near nuclear power plants
and different things like that so that
was you know so you believe in aliens I
don't know how you can I mean
aliens is is it an evolving term
thankfully cuz people just think of
little green men or et or whatever like
I don't believe that word alone in this
universe
there's billions and billions of
galaxies it's wow that doesn't make any
sense ridiculous and cocky is it to
think that were the only species in the
world like were the only human human
were the only beings in the world think
it's ridiculous it's not logical to me
but I mean I grew up in a
and the churches that would say that the
earth is 12 and 15 thousand years old
which is also ridiculous and you know
that there's nothing going on here like
how would it change our world if we knew
there was other other beings what do you
think would happen you would definitely
question people's beliefs for sure
especially the organized religion that
doesn't really have space for for aliens
because you know this is you know God
created the earth God created man this
is all there is there's nothing else out
there because it's not in the Bible or
it's not but many people would say that
there are references to otherworldly
other racial no I mean meaning that
human race like other alien type imagery
and words found in the Bible they're
obviously all over ancient cultures and
hieroglyphs and statues and paintings
and writings the things they're holding
things they're wearing the suits they're
wearing that stuff is all fascinating to
me and I think that you know there's a
lot of people interested in it it was
like ancient aliens sure and the one
that we want oh yeah that was fun the
blue blue book Project Blue Book Project
Blue is that an fx me or something yeah
but there's about real scenarios that
had happened and then they recreated the
show there's definitely some some
cover-up is going on yeah as well well
like you said it takes away from the
religion but it also takes down
government too because when that kind of
thing's been concealed by by someone
obviously if it has been and then if you
look at the religious side where you
know it doesn't leave room for that kind
of thing the whole house of cards falls
down yeah it's obviously about the end
of the world as we know it according to
the Bible but I know when I was the
younger I like think that oh my god the
world
gonna end but when you really think
about the words little differently you
go oh the worlds we know oh this could
be different yeah it's the end of the
world as we know it
alright enough about aliens I'm gonna
ask you questions these are gonna be fun
so these come from like close people
this wasn't some Instagram ask me send
me your questions for Erin this is this
is in house mmm okay you ready yes
when did you realize he could grow such
a badass mustache I was at the giraffe
to no.5 and all I had was the flavor
saver and I took took some heat for it
didn't you know the right here yeah oh
yeah I got it I got it didn't see
anything it looked good yeah it didn't
get what are you use about it other
people didn't I was one of us I we grew
up you know tombstones on my all-time
favorite movies you know yet her Russell
has a badass mustache Annette Paxton has
a mustache in that fouls mustache is not
as great Val Kilmer please know they but
he's a badass the movie his lines of the
best and then you got the goat Sam
Elliot with a stache I grew up watching
that movie and and you know my dad had a
mustache growing up so I always thought
they were funny and then I think early
into you know maybe oh seven oh six no
six I grew in on training camp I was
like why did you belong here
I started going oh six and broke my foot
and cut it then I grew up from November
oh six until June of seven yeah now
since I cut it thanks to you and your
confidence that it would look good what
would your final meal be or as it's
written actually death-row uniboob Juno
Juno voet
you know you can
a badass mustache no that's when I grow
my hair up good sorry you have any more
to elaborate on the mustache it's pretty
iconic and epic I always said
as a young person in my Tony's that
mustache is if you are under 35 then
your mustache needs to have some sort of
brevity joke to it will you fast that
now pretty much yeah
so now it's a little creepy at times but
I do enjoy it mmm I think it's funny
yeah I think I think that creepy goes
away when it covers the top lip as well
then it's totally cowboy Sam Elliott
Kurt Russell oh great yeah just like I
wear pencil ones kind of weird death
Romeo final meal Papa's bravas from
chives with that sauce Wow and you eat
that weakly I love it it's amazing
I'm gonna have to go in Dallas when we
won the Super Bowl
that Tuesday after we had media day I
went out to dinner with Chad Clifton and
Brett goood and had this pork chop that
they brought to the table and it was on
fire to start and I think I'm a little
biased because we had the Super Bowl I
was with two of my buddies but that meal
that was unbelievable
are you still in Dallas Oregon we're in
Dallas oh yeah and then you know got to
finish it off with a blizzard yeah or a
cupcakes a blizzard and cupcakes yeah
yeah well sure they make a cupcake
blizzard yeah actually cake in it yeah
so I'm going on three desserts I'm gonna
want a blizzard a half and a half I'm
gonna want some cupcakes just white on
white white frosting would you go with
standard like all like the normal or
would you want like a healthier version
I don't take you a healthy ones really
because I'm gonna add in the third
dessert which is a pie from Jordy
Nelson's grandma
I'm gonna put that in there as well what
kind of pie is it I mean the
Butterfinger Snickers it's and I'm and
I'm not sharing you don't have to you're
gonna die okay um game day routine like
at the stadium yeah I like to get in
early
put my early means like at least three
hours for the game and put my put my
jersey on my pads put up on my top on my
locker put my pads in my pants hang that
up make sure my cleats have new cleats
in them and they're ready maybe read the
program for a little bit if there's an
article and then kind of get my tunes
going and then study the plan a little
bit maybe do a crossword I kind of go
back and forth between that though
studying a plan doing across we're just
five and I listen to music and then do
some stretching routines I always get
stretched between 35 and like 25 minutes
before we go out for pregame warmups by
Levada our strength coach my marco bott
and then go through some breathing stuff
on the sidelines during the anthem and
during before the first drive and then
away we go what does that mean breathing
routines yeah I'd like to do some
breathing routines that help to slow
down my heart rate and ease I think
counted yeah so it's a it's a uh Nanao a
hold and an exhale and that's that goes
like I settle in I kind of shake out any
out my toes and my fingertips any any
negative energy and away we go
favorite household chore dishes what's
your least favorite
probably cleaning up throw up
these dogs throw up every now and again
what's something that would keep you up
at night what keeps you up at night this
isn't like a dogs barking this is a mind
thing like what keeps you up at night
what doesn't allow you to shut down hmm
I'm reading between the lines by the way
this it just says what keeps you up at
night I just think I have an active mind
and I like to think about a lot there's
a lot going on and not being able to
silence the thoughts won't keep me up so
it won't be like we're all curious I
know but it won't be like a specific
thing it's not like one specific thing
could be like conversation from that day
and what I got to do tomorrow and what I
gotta do this week and what I want to
get accomplished here and what's gonna
be my generous thing for this day and
you know just it could be who knows just
active - it's usually - it's usually a
to-do list so I either draw out my to-do
list or I have a mental to-do list and I
will remind myself at nighttime a lot of
times like when you wake up remember
this remember that so instead of I
putting my phone I'll just do it mental
yeah cuz that's everybody does that they
just put a mental list together but you
don't really have a hard time falling
asleep when you go to bed no you pretty
much her out like a light yeah I mean of
course you fall asleep in bed quickly
yeah when the mental or when the initial
question came in without your own
interpretation of it I would have said
you know a movie and it could be a movie
I've seen hundred times it could be the
Big Lebowski
or it could be Tombstone that comes on
back okay I guess I'll watch this again
well we'll check with Brooke what she
really meant by that question true
my sister thanks Brooke three things you
can't wait to do when you retire
skee skydive that's tough to say I don't
know you know I I do most of stuff I
want to do those things that obviously
don't want you to do but that really
don't make sense for me as well
like I loved playing basketball I don't
think well I can't wait to play
basketball you know what I'm done I just
don't play like I don't have a desire to
be out there and run around I like
shooting just stationary hoops but
there's not a ton of things that I don't
do that I really want to do I just think
it's more having time like I love I love
this this structure I mean I think
anybody in the league you love it and
then when you're offseason you just
enjoy and not having the structure and
then at some point it kind of creeps
back any like man I kind of yeah I kind
of Miss having something I got to do
every day
I believe that goes away at some point
you know the monotony of training camp
it will be nice to to not have that
anymore and to have your body feeling
good again that's what I look forward to
I look forward to my body really feeling
feeling good and everything healing up
from years of car crashes every week I
agree I know what you mean one thing you
want to do before you die I feel like
well yeah maybe one thing you want to do
free day I mean I don't really think
about that I think about stuff I want to
do but I don't think about the death
part I mean I want to travel that's the
big thing you know what is the most
important thing that you want to
accomplish in your life connection
up somewhere you want to somewhere you
want to go like somewhere that you for
sure want to go in your life Egypt we
connected on see that's kind of it
speaking of inaction we totally
connected on that when we when we first
started talking about places see that
and that you know what that's okay let
me now that you remind me of that before
I die I would like to stand between the
paws of the Sphinx good one let's
actually been mine for about five years
now yes
you kind of get into me a little bit cuz
keeping in mind they came from internal
internal people like my sister favorite
things about Danica I've been upset a
few of them cooking your amazing amazing
cook and you your discipline is
inspiring because it is crazy now I have
some good discipline when it comes to
food too but that's more like fasting
intermittent fasting yeah which you
struggle with but the I wake up hungry
yeah but that the health part is very
inspiring I mean your your work ethic is
inspiring you you know you put your mind
to something to do it like you whether
it's a workout or you know whether it's
a idea that's pretty impressive and then
you know your overall curiosity you know
you're just very interested in a lot of
stuff and if you don't understand it you
wouldn't know more about it you don't
shut down you've got a an open mind in
the best sense where are you the best
open mindedness does not include an
immediate reaction it's more of a I'd
like know more about that yeah instead
of thoughts [ __ ] I don't believe
that right thank you
how has Danica changed your life I can't
have it's my cheat day center for so
many reoccurring themes that's the
biggest way
and then now you know we got a couple
couple dogs hanging it out all the time
that's been fun they're good dogs they
are good dogs and they make life better
was it was the question do I feel like
I'm missing Oh hands Danica changed your
life
oh yeah so from a practical standpoint
yeah dogs no cheat days from a you know
emotional standpoint I think you're a
very steady person you know so that
that's been nice to have a steady steady
yeah energy you know like energetically
I think you have a steadiness about you
you know and you know who you are and
that brings even more calm to the house
which you know me I'm always about calm
and energetic cohesiveness and peace
yeah you're a peacemaker sometimes you
fight for it but the earpiece that's
right I fight for peace and if there
isn't peace then you just burn some sage
mm-hmm and Palo Santo I write poetry
have you picked up any driving tips from
me know what I mean
you're a really good driver fantastic
driver I mean you know how to turn an
apex exit the corner like what I always
tell you you may have been a
professional racecar driver but I'm a
professional in street driver highways
River you seem to not think there's
carryover between I've been driving the
car 40 years without a ticket without a
speeding ticket yeah that's not
something to be proud of if you're
talking about being a badass on the road
it means you just understand how to
drive over the speed limit and without
getting pulled over it's true you don't
drive slow if you haven't had many
tickets it is impressive safely drive
safely you do drive pretty safely I
haven't initiated an accident in my
driving career as well I think I've
scared people I think I probably [ __ ]
their pants on
and they lay on their horn when I do
things when I come not hurting you so
maybe I caused an accent I hope not
you're staying yo Lane hidden talents I
mean I feel like we covered some
interesting stuff with your intelligence
and like crosswords and that kind of
thing jeopardy but I can sing the main
when's it changed by the scorpions
karaoke you do love karaoke
I do did it hurt when I scored a hundred
that one night on Bohemian Rhapsody and
you didn't score 100 for a long time it
was score hundred that night I think you
did one was definitely skewed that night
on the machine at the house there's been
two 100's ever and they're yours
obviously no sir had one of them she's a
good singer
anything you're not good at yeah I'm
terrible at badminton
oh well that's life-changing I'm sorry
yeah not good at badminton I tried
wakeboarding when I was in high school
that was terrible at it tried surfing
before I'd like to try that again and be
good at that but not good at that you
see geez a little high center of gravity
thank you I understood that
can anyone hang with you in jeopardy Oh
Cheech Marin
she just won celebrity jeopardy of a
number of times thi Cheech and Chong oh
yeah Cheech I think Cheech good for sure
and everybody that one I watched you
know the other celebrity jeopardy
episodes from my year four years ago and
everybody that one was pretty smart
obviously I wasn't on there um
pregame playlist maybe even just name
some artists yeah your pregame playlist
is different then yeah I expect Skylar
in place you had Lord
there you got bony bear NACO Trevor Hall
John Bryant it's lots of open list here
lately the old favorites you know I love
Counting Crows
of course Pearl Jam Nirvana Foo Fighters
you know those are always on there not
mix it up you know do this some Pandora
sometimes you know last show I was on a
kick and kind of Johnny Cash there's a
couple songs a boy named Sue of course I
know that you know swingers reference
notice okay but it's your question turn
I think of one of their bands I need
that you listen to chill music that was
the point
yeah relaxing their data point which is
funny I've always been like that too
with everything I'm especially when I
was younger when I would go running or
work out I would listen to Norah Jones
like I would be listening to
I felt like my mom not anymore though
huh not anymore
well I do have a workout playlist yeah
it's all rap but the rest of the time
which you know we've mostly don't most
of listen to music we didn't watch TV I
love sports and I was surprised when you
when you're home alone and I'm like what
do you like when I'm not home and you
said well I can watch whatever I want
like well what do you watch and you said
i watch sports and I'm like that's all
we watch at home is for its you like no
but I was all for it golf I mean oh no
I'm not gonna subject you to watching
golf unless you know Jerry Kelly's
playing in or make you watch a lot of
golf I I don't mind golf I'm just saying
or soccer it's when you start matches
lower levels of like not the top level
of sports and you start watching high
school stuff that I'm like yeah I know
what's high school stuff maybe not but
something like it you college may be
their best concert
ever I'll give you a top three even
better
we saw NACO and Trevor hole ready rocks
that was unbelievable and you know that
one I love both of them as artists
they're just fantastic and then the
venue just puts it over the top yeah I
saw Tegan and Sara and Death Cab at the
Hollywood Bowl and again I've enjoyed
Tegan and Sara's music since my best
friend Joey introduced me to them you
know in like 2000 and who knows two
three
[Music]
but that venue dand they played with the
LA Philharmonic behind him the orchestra
and that concert was unbelievable and
then 2009 at the rave in Milwaukee which
is a great venue for music
The Killers did a standing-room-only
show and this is when they were rolling
and their CD the big CD just come out
big record yeah oh yeah I flailed around
to that song in the like mid 2000 mm mm
six seven ish oh my gosh okay and I went
the so my teammates and that show was
just unbelievable fun yeah yeah any show
where you know all the stuff you know
like yeah Foo Fighters I love those guys
their shows incredible and I've you know
seeing Eddie Vedder was unbelievable
because you know his his end of the wild
soundtrack is I could listen that on
repeat over and over and over and
again but those two venues I think and
then just with those three venues it
really it's all about the venues I saw
Pearl Jam and Bradley Center saw Foo
Fighters in Madison before and some one
at a time but those venues are just so
iconic and it'll watts of to watch them
in Red Rocks and the bowl and and then
the rave dance g2 right we talked about
energy a a long time ago in this
conversation and there's an energy to
those spaces too especially a good place
like I don't go to the other ones with
you but Red Rocks I went with you and
just like being in the mountain like in
the mountain and the positive vibes like
it makes it makes a difference
yeah I mean I've seen Stevie Nicks and
Prince before he passed was unbelievable
and you know Brad Paisley it's
incredibly talented puts on a great show
but those two your real talent you can
play the guitar and I know you tried to
tell you say because you're not very
good but you can play the guitar
I can strum I can finger pick Ben Harper
or love Ben Harper you might have been
playing Ben Harper guitars well I met
yes and I met him in cinema thank you
and he send me a guitar he's he's
awesome I mean you just one chord and I
was like oh my gosh that's Ben Harper
you're great you're great musician and
you're good singer and you're
self-taught impressive all right best
non-football sporting event favorite
Kentucky Derby oh yeah it was right you
know how many years in a row now
what's funny is the first year you want
was the only year I've gone what was the
2006 seven eight eight probably yeah
eight hello
math a bad for me good for you all right
these last three questions are from
Brooks girls they're from recent Dourdan
okay why are you such a knucklehead
because I'm stubborn nice answer thank
you I mean just for answering it for
real you are Severn that's a good
question yeah they're a couple of
knuckleheads favorite candy um and again
I don't really eat any candy anymore
unfortunately
but starburst jellybeans or the
starburst fave Reds to all the Reds
fantastic Reese's Peanut Butter Cup any
time the big Cup where it's mostly
peanut butter yeah I used to you know I
used to go the gas station and I would
get king-size Reese's purple crush why
is your moustache so huge I got a good
surface area yeah between my lip and
nose and then I enjoyed growing it out
over the top lip and every now and
bottom lip but it's a gift
yeah well I find it fascinating to ask
people what's your greatest life lessons
have been so you two greatest life
lessons I mean I feel like I've had a
lot of them lately you know in the past
five or six years I think it a lot of it
just revolves around being yourself you
know I think society and this culture I
think sets up a lot of stuff that's fake
you know social media is rooted in
filters and our best self you're not
gonna put shitty stuff out there you
know you're not gonna put stuff that
like real struggles out there and I
think that's teaching society that it's
not teaching them how to deal with
adversity just everything's always
hunky-dory and don't ever be mad about
anything and
ever always put your best side forward
you know because you never want anybody
to judge you and dealing with criticism
but just all this stuff wrapped into
people not knowing who they are or just
not being comfortable being themselves
being flawed and having scars you know
emotional scars wounding and I think
that was the biggest thing I remember
you know mental and mind when I was
younger told me the greatest challenge
is loving yourself ultimately and being
comfortable with who you are and that's
something that's that rings true for me
throughout my life and I think even more
lately is over the last you know half
decade is just being comfortable with
who I am and loving myself and enjoying
all the things about me that make me me
that quirky things the talent the
insecurities the struggles the process
the evolution and understand that's what
makes me who I am and that's it's
through the flaws and the frustrations
and the struggles that that the strength
emerges and greatness emerges because we
all have greatness inside of us it's
just trusting that and enjoying that and
stirring that up and just being
authentic you know that's what this
country and this world needs more of is
authenticity from people and less
fakeness unless [ __ ] you know
there's people being raw and being okay
with it and you know that's I think the
greatest life lesson because in my own
sport guys never respond when it's
contrived and when it's fake unoriginal
and guys respond when it's real when
it's raw emotion when it's a real tears
when it's real love it's real compassion
when it's real connection
it's good reminder you know there's a
lot of parallels between real life and
football you know a lot of life lessons
you can learn in football about dealing
with people and setting aside your ego
and being a part of something bigger
than yourself
you know how important doing the work is
and being able to work with other people
and inspiration and being self-motivated
so football has taught me a lot about
life but the greatest lesson that life
in football continues to teach you is
how can you expect people to feel love
from you when you don't love yourself
when you're not comfortable through your
confident start with that how far along
are you on that oh and I mean that's a
process for sure but that's part of the
process but I I think it's a lot of
those been the coming out of you know
some of the thoughts and ideologies from
your childhood I guess that's so normal
and natural and it's not a shot against
any of that and so thankful for the
lessons I learned growing up because I
didn't learn them and in that order and
that specific teaching and style there's
no way I'd be sitting here today because
I would have been I would have been
different but because as I grew an
awareness and consciousness and learning
you I had the naturally questioned the
things and the beliefs that you've had
and the agreements you've made with
yourself and your surroundings and
without that upbringing and that
knowledge as a kid there's no way I
would have figured started to figure
things out thank you
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today I hope you
enjoyed it and also thank you so much
Trevor hall for the awesome music if you
like what you heard today and you want
to hear more please click on the
subscribe button
[Music]